am vous n'échapperez pas jean-edouard à
une interview à peine d' attention ce
que vous préférez en vous mon coeur ce
que vous détestez en vous on est tombé
j'ai l'impression d'avoir une bouteille
à la place du génial j'ai l'impression
d'avoir sauvagement bien ton et séverine
tu n'aimes pas sonné j'ai l'impression
de squales et des yeux d'algues à ses
mains ce lot au gré des genres et loire
ce jeu vous préférez dans le théâtre et
trois coups la troupe le partage entre
les comédiens les émotions qu'on se
donne et qu'on reçoit ce que vous
n'aimez pas du tout le théâtre les
tensions ce que j'ai l'impression que
malgré tout chacun ses petites habitudes
est très grand et bas chacun ne veux pas
en changer et donc le tout c'est parfois
de savoir prendre sur soi ou de savoir
dire les choses clairement
le plus grand moment de votre vie le
sort de la générale le pire moment de
votre vie
le jour où mes deux grands parents ont
disparu et le congrès en l'occurrence
pendant que ce qui vous plaît le plus
dans la vie
l'ambition le fait de savoir de vouloir
mettre tout ce qu'on a en soi pour pour
arriver à quelque chose qu'on se fixe
est ce qui vous fait vraiment chier dans
la vie l'hypocrisie et tête de con votre
plus gros coup de fric plus gros coup de
fric
honnêtement alors là je crois que j'en
ai passé parce que toutes les fois où on
m'a proposé justement surtout après le
loft parce qu'avant j'étais on m'a
proposé de faire pas mal de choses et
mon plus gros coup de fric c'est d'avoir
refusé de faire lofteurs open homme qui
avait rapporté chacun quand même un gros
paquet de fric peu plus grosse perte
mes grands parents ouais bof plus belle
histoire d'amour
une jeune fille à l'époque où je
travaillais donc dans une discothèque
avec ce en provence avec qui je
travaillais j'étais tombé
follement amoureux d'elle et pareil
j'étais prêt à tout pour y arriver je
suis pas arrivé le plus minable histoire
d'amour celle là aussi oui j'en ai ligue
2 et les deux ont foiré donc pas choisir
fois trancher ce que vous avez des plus
sexy je sais pas un mais main même si
n'importe quoi je ne sais pas c'est un
très beau cul quand même si vous avez
deux mois sexy mon nez le pauvre mais
qu'est ce qu'il est avec sont vraiment
une obsession louise lui un très joli
nez jean edouard vous préférez dans le
sexe là le vrai diffuse des gouttes dans
le sexe ça existe la chevrette
qu'est-ce qui me dit dantec
des gouttes dans le sexe c'est certain
côté malsain qui peuvent être poussés
très beau ouais mais où j'irai pas tu
aimes pas le sexe mâle ça tout dépend ce
qu'on appelle massin pour les gens une
fellation sap est malsain et pour
d'autres coucher avec un cheval c'est
très malsain
ouais ça dépend qu'elle allait partir